[Música]
eu realmente fico emocionada e admirada
com pessoas que têm idéias próprias e
conseguem agregar pessoas ao redor dela
e com isso mudar seu meio
eu eu acho que eu nunca tive uma idéia
sim mas eu consigo agregar pessoas ao
redor de um projeto e a ele em prestar
meus instrumentos que foram sendo
adquiridos ao longo da minha jornada
eu vou contar um pouquinho pra vocês de
como foi aos 17 anos eu já me vi em
frente de um grande coletivo e esse
coletivo precisava diariamente entregar
um bom produto era técnica em nutrição
uma cozinha industrial
ali eu aprendi que é necessário olhar o
indivíduo na sua unicidade e valorizar o
que ele tem de mais especial para que um
produto coletivo saia gostoso como uma
boa comida mas a minha paixão era pela
alquimia e por isso eu optei por fazer
química
acontece que no meu caminho havia o
cálculo é e foi o encontro devastador
só não foi mais devastador do que
perceber que num coletivo em que as
pessoas procuram ampliar seus
conhecimentos como a universidade havia
a discriminação
nós éramos há 20 anos atrás um grupo de
mulheres em minoria no final das aulas
nós ouvimos coisas do tipo as burras tem
alguma dúvida
eu sai arrasada e fui procurar com fé um
curso que pudesse instrumentalizar
para entender melhor a sociedade no
papel
eu poderia ocupar nessa sociedade
felizmente eu cursei uma universidade em
que alguns professores abraçavam a boa e
velha escola do direito alternativo que
nada mais é o direito que privilegia o
justo a ética acima da aplicação da
norma fria
o coletivo humano ele tem que ser
privilegiado
segundo essa escola eu me apaixonei
contudo tocou o sinal e eu precisava
ganhar a vida
abracei com garra a primeira
oportunidade que apareceu em direito
empresarial
nessa porta encontrei paris que os
amigos e fundei a minha própria banca
foi bonito aquele direito lá da
graduação ficou pra trás
contudo havia um fato que iria mudar
minha trajetória um fato social
ah isso eu também encontrei um cliente
com uma ideia inovadora engenheiro mas
que precisava de alguns ajustes a ele e
me aliei ele nos procurou para patentear
o produto mas eu gostei tanto da ideia e
como eu era uma química frustrado ou
seja uma cientista
abracei o projeto me tornei sócio o
empresário o direito passou a ser apenas
um instrumento da minha vida empresarial
voltando ao fato que foi transformador
na minha trajetória 2006 crise do
sistema penitenciário são paulo virou um
caos a violência potente ônibus
queimando bombas explodindo em fóruns
que eu costumava transitar um toque de
recolher que deixou a paulista desde o
final da tarde tinha vazia
eu fiquei com medo tinha um filho
pequeno
fiquei com medo mas além do medo uma
questão lá da graduação
um beijo ressoar o pacto social seria
capaz de abarcar as nossas questões
éticas da modernidade
de que forma nós enquanto cidadãos
poderíamos contribuir para que o estado
conseguir sair desse dilema fugir
vim pra são carlos
que felicidade encontrar na usp
uma turma de tea algo que eu fazia lá na
graduação e à felicidade era maior
porque não se tratava apenas de um curso
de teatro
eu estava num lugar em que a maioria dos
alunos eram universitários
eu já beirando os 40 vivendo com a
garotada com a garotada com aquele
ímpeto da primeira do primeiro
descobrimento é uma energia
revolucionário potente
ninguém quer as coisas prontas e eu
percebi que eu precisava disso pra
continuar vem
resolvi montar a minha banca e que nem
uma porta simples para fazer uma
advocacia de outra forma o olho no olho
atendendo à necessidade do indivíduo
dentre os meus primeiros clientes me
aparecer um caso que foi marcante
eu conheci o caso pelos jornais
em muitos casos similares mas aquela
mulher
ao entrar no meu escritório porque foi
recomendada
ela pediu ela queria uma advogada mulher
e negra
quando ela entrou eu sentia a potência
do soco ela estava desfigurada
ela havia sofrido violência policial eu
fiquei com medo
eu fiquei com medo mas eu não pude
recusar a pedir ajuda
fui atrás de organizações achei a
comissão de direitos humanos da oab que
apesar de ser a minha instituição eu
nunca tinha dialogado com profundidade
em razão dessa trajetória eu me
aproximei da oab e foi quando me fizeram
um convite para que eu assumisse a
comissão de direitos humanos
não era minha cidade não era minha praia
o que será que eu posso fazer com
direitos humanos
comecei a estudar falar com professores
início chamei as pessoas que o conheciam
os coletivos de teatro
as organizações não governamentais
enchemos a oab estava ali pra saber o
que esse indivíduo precisava esse
coletivo precisava estava ali para falar
do direito que acreditava um direito que
é feito por nós pra solucionar questões
do nosso tempo é claro a norma está
pronto mas nós precisamos ter a
capacidade de manipulá la de
interpretá-la e de cobrar os órgãos
competentes não é só uma questão
política a questão é maior
nós temos um judiciário nós temos a
promotoria e um indivíduo precisa estar
a instrumentalizar a partir daí meu
trabalho começou a ser conhecido
as universidades me chamavam para fazer
parceria a minha característica a nossa
da comissão de direitos humanos passou a
ser a conjugação de várias formas várias
vertentes do saber para instrumentalizar
esse indivíduo 2016 eu bati na porta do
centro cultural da usp porque não tinha
verbas para fazer uma coisa que eu
queria muito que eu queria no mês do
aniversário da cidade e que é o mês da
consciência negra
falar de memória eu não queria falar de
igualdade racial eu queria falar dos
motivos que nos levam a ter essa
desigualdade e que à falta de memória a
nossa sociedade uma mesa com o cineasta
para falar dos afectos da cidade
um economista como historiador a uma
psicanalista que falava porque é que
isso se rompeu e ali eu conheci a usp os
seus núcleos em razão de
em 2017 nós somos chamados para fazer
uma parceria e conseguimos um edital
através do edital santander nós fizemos
algumas ações afirmativas em 2017 como
por exemplo uma aula inaugural com
palhacinhos que questionavam a questão
ainda há discriminação bem fui vivendo
fazendo realizando conforme as ações
sociais às intempéries sociais ocorrendo
nós viemos atuando nas ocupações das
escolas por exemplo
alguns pais de meninos que gostariam de
assistir aulas eles iam à noite e
apedrejavam escola
então nós estivemos ali como em outras
urgências sociais pra diminuir essa
tensão falar os limites de cada um
vivendo caminhão e sempre ouvindo acerca
do coletivo cerrado ficar num lugar que
é do meu coração mas eu entendia bem
qual é o trabalho o cerrado estava lá
dentro de uma universidade federal
ele deveria seria protegido cuidado com
tudo eu vi que uma licitação estava em
curso uma licitação para construir uma
estrada que atravessaria o cerrado
eu me preocupei não sabia bem quais
seriam as implicações mas eu sabia que
haveria implicações
fui até o coletivo cerrado quando me
disseram que estava tudo bem
o ministério público federal que é o
tutor de um bem tão importante quanto o
meio ambiente estava tratando do caso
mas a licitação estava em curso alguma
coisa eles a estava errado algo iria
acontecer com o cerrado não está tudo
bem sara você nem é da área eu continuo
insistindo até que eles resolveram
promover uma reunião com o ministério
público ali que surpresa
o procurador federal saca de um laudo
muito bem fundamentado para dizer que
ele era a favor da construção da estrada
ela só precisava ter critérios o
coletivo finalmente entendeu que algo
precisava ser
feito e ali eu entrei o que precisava
ser feito era a promoção de uma ação
popular ação popular nada mais é do que
o povo dizendo este bem é importante
este bem precisa ser protegido e a
entidade o gestor não está fazendo
demandamos bem 2014
e se bem é protegido em razão de uma
tutela de urgência e tudo parece levar a
crer que vamos ganhar e quando me falta
a palavra vivem a poesia adquirida nesse
percurso todo com tantos encontros
especiais e é com ela que eu encerro
para dizer o que faltou sonhos
invulgares em dias de seguir algoz
impossibilidades visíveis pelas diversas
formas possíveis implodindo estridente
agonia em mundo silêncios pasmos cruzo
naturalmente atlânticos continentes
encobertos desvelam se outras esferas
só é preciso paris quem com cinta sonhos
invulgares contra toda ordem ressecadas
retinas vem conjuga conjuga te a mim sem
buscar cura concerto fazer planos de
seguir a rota pra lua começa por livrar
se de sonhos decantados de visitar a
terra pisar nela inteiro comercial fruto
inteiro olhar o céu dia-a-dia descobrir
quem se é um lugar onde se está a vida
inaudita vai recrutando aos poucos
sonhos nascem sólidos quando se é
inteiro
[Aplausos]